My protocol includes supplements for detoxified, should something else be added when detoxing
from chemo.
I created a blog post about five or so years ago, mainly for people that aren't for patients.
And it has some different things to do and not to do while you're going through chemo.
But I really should edit that blog post and not worry about people that hurt our patients.
Because it does give you some other things to do to detox the chemo.
Now I've switched years ago to making suggestions on a personal basis to our patients.
So if a person is doing chemo from a standard standpoint, so they're doing chemo, should they detox
them?
Should they do things to detoxify the chemo itself?
Well, there's a theory, which I adhere to, that chemo really does the majority of its work
within the first 48 hours of administration and after that it could just be toxic to our bodies.
So after that, we do want to support detoxification pathways.
Now I already have everybody on some things.
Should we add some things to help with that?
Look at what I add.
So when I make a recommendation based upon a cheek swab test, we want to stick to that until
we get some of the other data back.
And we get your genetics back that shows that certain pathways need more support than
we would add that.
Or if a person started chemo before we got their genetics back, and let's say they just
did really poorly with the chemo because we've had that before, because that's an indication.
So if a person does chemo, let's say they had chemo on Monday, and then by Wednesday they
were throwing up sick, and they had to take anti-naudia medicine, they were in bed, it just
literally wiped them out for three days.
What does that tell us?
Well, there's a tell us point that chemo was too strong, they need to dial that back a little
bit.
Maybe that's a conversation that one would need to have with their oncologist.
Does it tell us that the chemo was working?
Well, well, not really, it tells us that you had adverse effects of that chemo.
What it mostly tells us is that you don't detoxify that chemo therapy very well.
So if a person has severe adverse reactions to a chemo therapy, that gives us an indication
that you don't detoxify that chemo therapy very well.
Chemo therapy's detoxified partially on the pod pathway, different cytokine, cytokine,
P450 pathways, and different net pathways, MAT pathways.
So if you're reacting, people that react poorly to it, they probably have a lot of defects
on those pathways.
They're just slower detoxifiers of things that have to go through that pathway.
There are some people, and some people that might be listening to this call, that they did
six rounds of chemo and had almost no ill effects, maybe a little bit of nausea, but
they just kind of soared right through that.
I just talked to a gentleman today that did chemo for his prostate cancer, had literally
no ill effects, and he's doing great and no ill effects.
What's that tell us?
Well, that tells us that he has really good detoxification pathways from a genetic standpoint.
And sure enough, we did his genes, and he does have really good detoxification pathways.
So your ability to get rid of things has to do with not just your genes, but the genes
do play a big role of that.
So if you have defects on your detoxification pathways, you're going to be a slower detoxifier.
It also has to do with things beyond genetics, meaning how healthy your liver was going
into this whole situation.
If you had exbed exposed to different toxins, alcohol, other environmental toxins throughout
your life, that damaged your liver, then you're going to be a slower detoxifier, even if
you don't have any genetic defects on your detoxification pathway.
So there's different factors, genetic and epigenetic factors that can slow a person's rate of detoxification
and if your rate of detoxification is hindered, then you're going to have more ill effects
from any toxin that you're exposed to.
So an individual basis, then, should I add supplements, other nutrition, help me detox if
I don't know what my genetic pathways are, well, then I would go, how are you doing symptom-wise
post chemotherapy?
I'm doing pretty good.
Well, then I wouldn't change anything.
I'm doing it horrible, okay, then we did ever talk.
So that's how I would make that decision.